the Motion Picture Association of
America wields tremendous power in the
film industry most major theater chains
will refuse to screen movies that
haven't been rated by the MPAA or which
have been assigned to the dreaded nc-17
meaning no minors no matter what
naturally this system incentivizes both
studios and filmmakers to satisfy the
ratings board standards but the
anonymity and sometimes inscrutable
logic of the MPAA has led to a number of
controversies here are the films that
were slapped with ratings that were too
strict too lenient or just plain strange
hunchbacks hypocrisy Disney's animated
output between the late 80s and early
90s is referred to as of Renaissance for
good reason beginning with the Little
Mermaid and culminating with the Lion
King their films racked up critical
praise box office returns and
recognition unheard of in decades then
in 2001 Atlantis the lost Empire assured
in the era of PG being the norm for
Disney but just before the turn of the
millennium The Hunchback of Notre Dame
snuck through with a pretty
inappropriate G but I'd never fit in out
there I'm not although the studio
streamlines the dense original story
from the 1831 novel the villain still
confessed his lustful passions in prayer
during the Hellfire musical number some
parents expressed concern but not enough
to hold hunchback back from financial
success a harrowing Hobbit as the final
film in Peter Jackson's two middle-earth
trilogies The Hobbit the Battle of the
five armies holds a singular place in
film history each Lord of the Rings and
Hobbit film has received an extended
edition that includes more material from
Tolkien's books than its theatrical
counterpart
life is worth more than that is doesn't
know the first five of these maintained
their original theatrical rating of
pg-13 but Battle of the five armies
bonus twenty minutes of footage got an R
an oddly severe rating given that Hobbit
fans had likely already seen Return of
the Kings depictions of severed heads
being flung by catapult the two Dark
Knight one case of outrage over movies
rating was so severe it altered the
course of an entire multimedia franchise
Tim Burton's Batman became an instant
pop-culture landmark in 1989 by
presenting a more serious take on the
Caped Crusader but many thought his
second outing went too far
Batman Returns bears the same pg-13
rating as its predecessor but its script
introduced a heavy innuendo and
psychosexual themes and then there was
the penguin who had a tendency to ooze
black bile
according to den of geek the backlash
made serious waves at Warner Brothers
and the reins to the next Batman
Adventure would be handed over instead
to Joel Schumacher who delivered the
bright neon action of Batman Forever
babes barnyard carnage George Miller may
be known for his Mad Max movies but he's
also made significant diversions into
Family Fare with the happy feet and babe
series the latter was a whimsical fable
with a heartwarming ending but it's G
rating masks some surprisingly dark
content true to Miller's style babes
themes run deeper than meets the eye
mortality looms over the barnyard with
most of the characters reminding babe
that his purpose is to be devoured by
his human bosses the Academy Awards even
took note of babes mature themes
nominating it for seven honors including
Best Picture psycho sexuality it was
nearly impossible for American Psycho to
not cause controversy one part of me
wants to take her out and talk to her be
real nice and sweet and treat her right
and what the other part of him thinking
putter head would look like on a stick
according to Variety the film initially
received a rating of nc-17 weirdly
enough though what pushed it past the R
wasn't the graphic and gleeful murdering
committed by Christian Bale's character
a single nonviolent sex scene director
mary harron explained why she found the
rating objectionable saying that Bateman
is looking at himself in the mirror and
not at his partners seems to be an issue
for the MPAA but his expression sums up
his frightening lead attached
relationship to the world around him
rating the reality of bully
documentaries present a unique challenge
to the MPAA but no rating caused more of
an uproar than 2011 s documentary bully
[Music]
director Lee Hirsch made the film to
feature issues faced by American
children but the MPLA declared bully and
ARF a language meaning the demographic
depicted in the documentary would be
unable to see it without a parent and
schools would be unlikely to host
screenings according to cinema blend
Michigan high school student Katie
Butler launched a change.org petition
that amassed over half a million
signatures protesting the rating still
the MPAA refused to budge Hirsch
eventually prepared a pg-13 version that
toned down the language the original cut
was also released but limited to
theaters willing to screen unrated films
a wilder bunch in 1995 Warner Brothers
prepared a director's cut of Sam
Peckinpah's 1969 classic The Wild Bunch
that restored ten minutes of material
trimmed from the original release for
time an SF Gate review praised the new
release saying the restored material
does not call attention to itself it was
there in the first place and it fits
right in but while the Wild Bunch was
rated R in 1969 the MPLA slapped the
director's cut with an nc-17 respected
film anchors fought the revisionist
rating citing the fact that the nc-17
would limit the film's availability the
MPLA eventually relented to an appeal
from Warner Brothers and released the
director's cut with an R but the
incident still stands as an example of
the ratings board's imperfection thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]